that's how powerful we are the story We
Tell ourselves is how we perceive the
world then when we create the
difficulties in our life it reaffirms
the belief that life is hard that it's
really someone out there that's doing it
to us that it's a circumstance in the
past that created this okay let's take
away the person that did it let's shoot
him to the Moon let's erase your past
what are you going to do now you still
got to do something right you're still
alive I say we already know how to do
this we already know how to do this
we're wired to be creators we're wired
to do this the thing that stops us for
the most part in doing it is really the
hormones of stress because living and
stress constantly is living in survival
living survivals living in emergency in
an emergency it's not a time to create
an emergency it's not a time to open
your heart it's not a time to learn it's
not even a time to sit still
so most people then that are living in
stress and living in survival they can't
believe in a future yet because it's not
a time to create so getting people to
that point where they make up their mind
enough to begin to think there's got to
be a better way there's got to be
something else hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from some of the best
and pick up some steps to reprogram your
mind enjoy
that Awakening process typically happens
when people reach their lowest
denominator
they hit rock bottom because then they
can see themselves Through The Eyes of
somebody else you're you feel so altered
you're not returning any texts you feel
so altered you want to go to dinner with
your buddies you feel so altered you
know you don't want to watch your
favorite TV show you're just you're just
disconnected and that's when you start
observing yourself
but my message is why wait for that I
mean you can learn and change in pain
and suffering or you can learn and
change and joy and inspiration if you're
waking up every morning being defined by
a vision of the future
instead of the memories of the past and
you get up and you're inspired from an
elevated self now instead of a limited
self you could observe the old cell from
an elevated State instead of that
diminished State and people are doing
that so they are aware
of those thoughts and yes it takes uh
effort and if it was easy everybody
would be doing it but just because you
have a thought doesn't necessarily mean
it's true and when you start looking and
observing those thoughts
um I think you are like Gandalf because
Gandalf also said you know you may not
pass you know when he meant like that's
kind of severity when it comes to how we
we make up our mind about things that's
the kind of energy or intention that
begins to create the biggest volume of
change in our life and I've interviewed
thousands of people in our work that
have
healed from really serious health
conditions and I would say about 90 of
them when I asked them so what happened
the first thing they say all the time is
I just made up my mind I just made up my
mind I was going to do this and they
made a decision
with such firm intention that the
amplitude of that decision
carried a level of energy that was
greater than the hardwired programs in
their brain and the emotional
conditioning in their body and the
choice that they made caused their body
to respond to a new mind in fact the
choice they made became a moment that
they would never forget it was an event
and the stronger the emotion they felt
the more they paid attention to the
choice in a sense they were remembering
their future and the body emotionally
was getting a sampling a taste of the
future and they are lying to that future
and
that's when the body's healing began
that's when the miracle started right in
that moment that's how powerful really
are now what if you did that every day
what if you made up your mind every
single day you weren't going to get up
from your meditation until you were that
person you wanted to be game on now
because you'd have to do battle
with all the things that are not
consistent with it and that's exactly
how our brain works so then if you want
to be wealthy you can't feel lack
you want to be a master you can't judge
your co-worker you want to be like
somebody great in history then you
better execute peace in every area of
your life that's that's the law so
you take the prayer out on the road now
you take the prayer you're the living
example of the prayer that's where
that's where it matters the most and
that's when people start getting
suspicious and say Sean man you change
your medication I mean you're looking
way too happy all of a sudden well
you're not relying on anything outside
of you to bring your joy you're you're
you're overcoming yourself every day and
people say to me well why do you do your
meditations in the morning I always say
easy because if I can overcome myself at
the beginning of the day the rest of the
day is easy right because that's the
biggest that's the biggest Mastery right
is the self step number two practice
proper manifestation with Gabby
Bernstein and I hear this from so many
people Gabby I'm doing it all I'm
meditating I'm praying I'm setting
intentions creating vision boards but
I'm not manifesting one reason you're
not manifesting is because you don't
believe in what you're trying to
manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy
and so you have to do your part to get
into the belief system of knowing that
this is indeed something you are worthy
of so how do you get into that grounded
belief system create a vision statement
a statement that claims that your desire
is on the way that you are worthy of
what it is that you desire ground
yourself in that statement focus on it
and instead of focusing on the outcome
focus on the feeling of what it is to
believe and know that you are worthy of
your desire if you're wanting to attract
a romantic partner into your life a
vision statement could sound like I
believe I'm worthy of the love that I
desire or I believe that I am ready to
receive that romantic relationship in
the perfect time and Order say that
vision statement daily for at least 40
days get yourself grounded in the belief
you have to believe it to receive it the
next reason you're not manifesting
because you're trying too hard
sorry to say it but it's true the more
you push the more you control the more
you try the more you affirm the more you
vision board more than more the more the
less you receive if you're pushing and
you're controlling and you're trying to
make something happen you are completely
out of alignment with the universe
you're not aligned with that freedom
that presence of Love The Art of
allowing rather than doing forcing
making happen yeah we have to show up
for our life but we can't force our
dreams to become a reality so the key
here is to let go so here's your message
the secret to manifesting is to forget
what you think you need let it go how do
you let it go with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
what do you mean well what I mean is
that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging a lot you are focusing on
scary things that make you so anxious
and you just keep focusing on them and
dwelling on them you're obsessed with
worrying you love to overthink things
look I understand that behavior more
than anyone could imagine I'm a
recovering Warrior I'm a recovering
anxious person I've been there I
understand that but when we are not in
that vibration that's relaxed released
at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff lean into the positive
look for Solutions rather than problems
stop yourself when you notice that
you're being judgmental or gossipy hang
out with people that make you feel good
do things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracting what you desire just relax
it's all good focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally we have the power
within us to attract what we desire when
we allow our internal condition to
reflect what we want to attract on the
outside so make that your highest
priority step number three visualize
fully with Rhonda Byrne hi Rhonda
whatever I want to manifest something I
will be giving that thing my attention
that's right you will
I get to see glimpses of the things that
I want to manifest after thinking about
them but they just glimpses they've
never truly manifested
so I guess if I want to manifest
anything I have to think about them with
the feeling that it's already in my
possession
if not they will just be glimpses and
not manifest am I right on this and this
is from Eden edham from Singapore
yes you are right in that you need to
feel as though you have your
manifestation in your possession for
sure I mean sometimes it's possible to
just think something and it manifests
too but if it's something we really want
we kind of need to pull in all of our
power right we need to bring in feelings
as well and really kind of get behind it
and and sort of supercharge it
um but I want to just say with glimpses
because I know what you mean by glimpses
but if you want you can interpret
glimpses as a sign of land that your
manifestation is about to arrive right
and you know a sign of land like Sailors
when they're out on the ocean and and a
sign of land would be seeing Twigs on
top of the water or something like that
or seeing some birds flying overhead
they would be signs of land they know
land is close by and so I would always
use
it glimpses as a sign of land and I
would be like
it's coming it's coming it's about to
arrive and so maybe that will help you
um maybe that will help you if you see
glimpses as as a sign that your
manifestation is about to arrive also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Step number four start changing
with Mel Robbins what is it that you
want to create or change in your life
okay I want you to write something down
if could be something tiny that there's
like a specific thing that you want to
change a specific habit or it could be
something really big and it's important
that we start there because I want you
to
have the thing that you want in mind
as I'm talking okay what is it that you
want to create in 2022 wealth stability
you want to stop
procrastinating right you want to create
Independence you want to feel like
you're aligned you want to get your
education you want to change your
exercise and eating habits you don't
want to be a passenger in somebody
else's life anymore you want to be The
Driver of your own life that's fantastic
and as I talk and as I teach I want you
to continue to think about this goal
that you have to think about this change
that you want to make okay and what
we're going to talk a lot about today
is we're going to talk about this
principle
that I believe
and the principle is this
profound personal and professional
change starts with you
that's right profound personal and
professional change starts with you
and change starts with you because the
most effective change starts from the
inside out okay and so as you think
about a behavior change or a thinking
pattern change that you want to make or
some sort of goal or dream I want you to
take everything that I'm about to teach
you
and have that example in mind okay so
that everything that I'm talking about
isn't just stuff I'm doing in my life
isn't just stuff that you read about uh
when you look at the research in terms
of habits and manifesting but you
actually walk away with takeaway that is
specific to what you want to achieve
step number five control your mindset
with John azeraf there's one thing that
I know can help even in these crazy
times can you guess what it is
mindset
let me explain what I'm thinking about
it's easy for us to focus on all the sh
that's going on that isn't right in the
world all the stuff that's not to our
taste all the stuff that's
uncertain unpredictable that's really
really easy for us to get hyper fixated
especially with everything that we're
watching on TV listening to the podcasts
are all talking about it the newspapers
the news feeds uh Instagrams and and
YouTubes everybody's talking about how
bad things are
but I also know that you and I can focus
on what can I do about this
how can I be healthier happier wealthier
is it possible that your trillion dollar
brain has the ability to focus and
achieve more
in times of crisis in times of
uncertainty
I know the answer is yes
so a couple things that may help you
first and foremost if you're feeling
anxiety or stressed or uncertain about
your current circumstances or your
future
one of the ways to deactivate that
stress Center in your brain is simply
taking six deep breaths in through your
nose gently
actually go ahead and do it with me
right now in through your nose as slowly
as you can
and out through your mouth as slowly as
you can
again
now all the latest brain science
shows that taking sixth breaths seven
breaths in slowly and out slowly
actually deactivates the stress Center
of your brain the anxiety Center of your
brain the part of your brain that if you
don't get anxiety and stress in check
could lead to panic and who the hell
wants to panic right now there's enough
panic in the world right
one of the reasons you want to take some
deep breaths maybe every hour
is by doing that you're actually going
to activate what I call is the Einstein
part of your brain and that's the part
of your brain that can actually think
through the problems that you may be
facing but also
it's the part of your brain that can
show you the path to achieving success
even in these crazy times when we're in
a state of stress or anxiety or
uncertainty
our blood pressure goes up we're
releasing the stress hormones we're
taxing our adrenal glands we're taking
blood flow away from the genius part of
our brains and what you want to do is
reactivate that and you have to do that
deliberately at first until you train
your brain to do it on an ongoing basis
so why not set aside
three minutes or five minutes every hour
to get calm so you can respond to all
the crazy instead of being stressed and
reacting to all the crazy and
reactivating that stress cycle and
anxiety cycle over and over again
now I know times are tough out there for
a lot of people
I know times are stressful
but mindset is what separates the best
from the rest
and you can train your mindset to focus
on the opportunities in every crisis
there are people that thrive there are
companies that get formulated that
become the greatest unicorns you know in
the business world
well if some people can do that
can you
I know you can so set some time aside
get calm decide on what you want ask
yourself what can I actually do to
achieve what I want regardless of what's
happening out there if I take care of
what's happening in here and in here
I can conquer what's happening out there
and step number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is
activate manifestation with sad Guru so
wherever your desire is that's where
your mind will be
if you desire something intensely your
mind will be always there right now you
desire the cup wrong place to be
you desire a goal that's what you should
desire when you're on the field isn't it
now you can decide
but once you're on the field you just
desire the goal and go and go nothing
else once your desire is strong your
body and mind naturally moves in that
direction isn't it whatever you desire
that's where you go
if your desire falls off then you can't
keep the mind on it
you just have to develop the icha in you
the only itcher is to score the call
then you don't have to worry about
mental focus that's where the mind will
be
[Music]
can somebody take your mind off what you
desire
can somebody take your mind off what you
desire what you desire is where your
mind will naturally go isn't it
so how does yoga help in this
see what are the simple parameters with
which the body and mind is functioning
this is a complex machine
this is the most sophisticated machine
in this planet is human body and mind
isn't it
everything that we have created has come
out of this mind so this mind is a
complex missionary very complex
[Applause]
so if you do anything wrong it will
create many distractions with
there are some simple ways there is some
simple technology with which you can
keep your mind in a certain condition of
clarity where it's increases that you
learn to keep your mind like a mirror it
simply shows you what is there it
doesn't distort
the moment your mind gets identified
with many things now you are playing as
an Indian hockey player now you get all
this started because now you're reading
the whole history the glory of Indian
hockey the depths of Indian hockey
everything will flow in your mind now
you will not play the game you will not
see the game the way it is first of all
learning to keep the mind like a mirror
where it simply shows you what is there
in front of you without any distortion
once there is no Distortion you will
walk to the best of your ability isn't
it
now you're walking on this floor there
is no Distortion in Your Vision you can
see everything clearly
to the best of your ability you will go
isn't it in your very Vision if there is
distortion
you will unnecessarily stumble all over
the place
so whatever talent you have whatever
capability you have if it has to find
full expression your mind doesn't come
in between a distort anything it just
shows you everything the way it is
so the whole yogic system is focused on
this for a spiritual purpose which can
also be used for the sport that it shows
you everything just the way it is not
some other way not the way you think it
is
let me explain what happens to this
really interesting concept called ghosts
in the nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated and
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and Mom or Dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on May 17
1972 but your nervous system remembers
what it's like so fast forward You're
Now 51 years old
and you walk in the house and there's a
mess everywhere and even though you have
said I'm not going to bulldoze and yell
at anybody
my body recognizes the situation
so what do you do you repeat the pattern
you saw
and so what I'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
I was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for share the mic for share the mic
now
um trying to create a video and I'm like
doing take after take because I want to
get it right and my daughter comes
Waltzing into the room and was like how
long are you gonna be doing this
and I was like
you said it I literally like screamed at
her and she looked at me Louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how old is
your daughter
20. and I said I I calmly said you're
right I do
when I get interrupted
I lose control of the response and I'm
working so hard and the way that you and
I'm clearly not mastering this yet but
the way that you do it is as you feel it
rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath you
can notice the pattern and you've got to
create a pause between the emotion
rising up and the reaction that gets
automated and for many people the
reaction Lewis is to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you hate being erupted by
anything this is a great interview I did
like I didn't do it I didn't do the
bulldoze I was I was calm because it
wasn't a human being I'm only mean to
human beings
um I know like I a lot of people run
away they avoid conflict they say it's
just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict continues to create a pattern
where you feel invisible and your
boundaries are tromped on that's a
pattern and you know here's the other
thing about patterns running away and
being quiet might have saved you when
you were little because if you were
quiet and out of the room you didn't get
hit you didn't get yelled at you were
out of Harm's Way so when you were
little it was a genius pattern because
it protected you but the issue for
adults is that again we walk around with
the patterns that we created when we
were eight years old in different
situations than we are in now and now we
are completely a robot to these patterns
the beautiful thing about monk life is
half the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
odd days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected I know
exactly whereas when my morning routine
is weakened I feel weak and so for me
the morning routine as I get strategic
about it there's two principles you have
to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you will feel hungry you will feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
well is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise we live in a world that
reinforces a scarcity mentality and that
mentality keeps us an energy of lack it
keeps us from attracting the career path
that we want the abundance that we want
and allowing us to really live our
purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways the first block is a lack mentality
and when we have a belief system around
lack we create more lack in our life we
all have stories from our childhood how
our parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough and if we feel like we
don't have enough we do a lot of work to
try to prove to the world that we are
enough the second block is the belief
system that there's not enough to go
around we often overwork to try to get
it all we're constantly trying to get
get because we don't believe that there
is enough it makes us feel like we have
to work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow of abundance the third block
is the block of comparison we literally
just turn on our social media and we're
immediately into compare compare compare
and comparing blocks or attracting power
because it focuses us on what we don't
have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
When We Fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want but it's
important to understand that rejection
can be protection when we have some form
of rejection show up in our life it's
the universe guiding us to something
better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance I want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to flow to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment so
if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
more we are in that service mentality
the more positively the universe
responds to us puts you into an
abundance mentality quickly because the
more you give the more you will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous and you're
no longer separating yourself from
others redirect your focus from what can
I get to how do I feel and really allow
that feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire what is fear is fear
something that you should fear
no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open isn't the signal
in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how does it keep us
alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential Threat
predator or threat at the door it lights
up the fear signals since cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine into your
bloodstream so you either know how to
fight it you run away or you freeze
hoping that the Predator will go away so
when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then knowledge then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed would succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I can put on
social media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stained stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking the voice within us that
believes that we are not allowed to be
happy
our card today is speaking to that
I believe I'm worthy of feeling good I
believe I am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to suffer to
succeed that we have to feel pain to
have purpose that we have to have
struggles in order to feel a sense of
Serenity in our life that is all quite
backwards it's when we feel good that we
actually attract more of what we want
into our life but we have to undo the
belief system that says who am I to feel
good who am I to feel great who am I to
be happy that belief system is an
ingrained belief system that can be
cultural that can be something that we
learned from our upbringing it can be
something that we have picked up from
this difficult experience that we're
going through right now with covid when
we witness people suffering we think
well how dare I be happy I would say to
you how dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group Collective happiness that
raises the energetic frequency of the
world if we those of us who have moments
of happiness and Grace and joy and
success and we don't celebrate them we
are doing the world a disservice we are
shutting down the light we are bringing
down the vibration so we we have to when
we feel good we have to reach for more
when we feel good we have to recognize
that that good feeling emotion has
momentum it has power it elevates our
children it elevates our family members
it elevates our friends it elevates
strangers on the street it is your
Divine Duty here on Earth to bring forth
that greatness that goodness that light
so when you hear that voice that says to
you you are not worthy of feeling good I
want you to hear my voice come through
and say to you who are you not to feel
good
this is your Divine Purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me we are more
comfortable being uncomfortable than we
are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
Corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but I wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or I didn't do that right I
want you to speak back to that voice I
want you to say thank you for sharing
but I choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but I don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but I'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and Grace sharing
that happiness joy and peace with so
much grace
that's what you're here for at the end
of your day or week do you ever find
yourself worried or frustrated because
no matter how much effort you put in to
work and no matter how hard you work
your financial situation and your
financial future may never seem to be
improving you might be finding yourself
living paycheck to paycheck right now
with not a lot of breathing room and I
would imagine no discretionary income or
even time to spend on the little things
that really would make your life more
enjoyable well what I can share with you
is you're not alone that's number one
and in most cases the real problem is
not your current circumstances what the
real problem is that most people repeat
the same path patterns of thought and
behaviors over and over again and that
is the cause of what more of the same
results but they are looking for
different results and so today I'm going
to show you how to break that pattern
break that cycle now you see when you
think of your results your results are
effects and so the question is effects
of what and the answer is your results
are all effects of what you believe to
be true about yourself what you believe
to be true that is possible and it also
comes down to what are your daily habits
now if you think about what you believe
and if you think about your habits that
is what is causing the effect that you
may not like right now and so as simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if I could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and I
could create more empowering habits than
my result will change and what I love to
focus on having done an enormous amount
of brain research over the last 10 years
is something called your inner game and
your inner game is comprised of
obviously your beliefs your attitude
your perceptions how you see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action and so
let me share just a little story with
you that may help you understand what I
mean
about two years ago I was at a seminar
and when I got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and I could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and I saw tears
streaming down her eyes and when she got
through the crowd for a moment I thought
that maybe there was something wrong but
she actually had tears of joy in her
eyes and when I met her her name was
Joni Sanderson and this was in Perth
Australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and I go well for what
she says well
about a year ago I heard you speak about
beliefs and habits and mastering my
emotions and really working on my
self-worth and she said to me that she
was a caregiver and that she loved
helping families who needed extra
assistance for their aging parents or
for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a Widow's pension of about twelve
thousand Aussie dollars a year and so
she really didn't have enough money to
be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so I shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said I don't know
and when I shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth and she said to me I think I'm
worth more I said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level of your brain you have
this feeling that maybe you're not smart
enough or not good enough or not worthy
enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior and so what I helped Joni do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was I helped her recognize
that beliefs Drive Behavior beliefs
Drive emotions habits Drive behavior and
in order to change your results living
paycheck to paycheck being stressed out
worrying about your future even your
presence circumstances right now why not
focus on working on the neural patterns
the beliefs and habits that are nothing
more than patterns in the brain that
drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and so
she started to work on what I call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and more empowered and what I
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widows from
a Widow's pension and living paycheck to
paycheck
to being able to charge for her Services
as she was making 75
000 a year your personality literally ad
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called the memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on with
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
hour away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened or it's happening
to you so the moment you open your heart
and you feel gratitude well that emotion
then is telling the body that the
experience has already occurred and the
thought then can make it into the body
because it's consistent with the thought
so now you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email then I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life becoming a monk was
my biggest dream growing up from that
time period that I made the monk 18
which we spoke about the last time I was
here and so that became like my identity
from 18 to 22 and then 22 to 25 when I
lived as a monk so it's like that's been
my identity for seven years at least in
my heart and my head and so when you get
to the end of a self-awareness Journey
which is actually the beginning but you
get to the end of it because you're like
oh I'm not a monk anymore and I'm sure
you've gone through similar things like
oh I'm not a CEO anymore of this right
of a business that does this or someone
else may go through I'm not married
anymore
I'm now divorced I am now not single
anymore or I'm not alone I've got kids
right it's like we all go through these
identity transitions in our life and to
me going from being among to not being a
monk was the hardest transition that I'd
been through at that time
and the question that I'm having is
I'm having Reflections on who I truly am
and what my skills are what my strengths
are what my passion is what my
compassion is and I'm saying I want to
share all of this in like a cool way
through entertainment and I love movies
and that's where the book's full of like
pop culture references and it's it's a
it's it's who I am and what I love about
myself
and then I'm going but this doesn't
align with what monk life is meant to be
in a sacred way
and that is like looking in the mirror
and going oh like I'm not comfortable
with that so when I share that with my
teacher and we're having this discussion
here's his advice and I think that's the
part that you're referring to he says to
me that
there's
students that come to University
and then they become professors and
there are students that come to the
university and then they go out and
become entrepreneurs or go out and work
and he says which do you think are
better
I'm like I mean neither really like I
can't really choose what makes someone
better and he was just like that's the
point you you came here
some people stay at the monastery and go
on to become senior monks and teachers
and some people will go out and do what
they do outside and he goes but then
either is better and it was the simplest
advice it's one of those pieces of
advice that it's all about the person
that says it and not necessarily what
you're hearing but for me it just
clarified the Judgment I had
the attachment I had
that I could only be happy and
purposeful in this way and that's really
what we're all struggling with that
currently we all have a projector screen
up here that goes this is what life's
meant to look like for it to be happy
and then down here we have the reality
version of what life actually looks like
and we go oh no they don't match that
doesn't match that's not working that
means I'm going on the wrong direction
the funny thing is the version you have
doesn't exist at all it's just an
imagination it's it's virtual reality
and the reality that you're experiencing
could actually be getting you closer to
that goal than you even think but you
just don't want to go down that path
because it doesn't look like the one you
imagine and that's where I was at I was
having to go down a path that I didn't
imagine looked like success but then the
question is well what does success look
like then and it definitely doesn't look
like the version in your head
so to me I started to realize and I
genuinely believe this
and your affirmation is very useful to
me the three years of my life living as
a monk were like being at monk school
and the last seven years have been the
exam
and everything in this book is stuff
that I've tried and tested in the last
seven years I learned it among school
but I tested it in in reality and I'm
only sharing what in the last seven
years has perfectly worked for me to
feel like I'm exactly where I need to be
doesn't mean I don't have off days that
doesn't mean that I'm happy all the time
it doesn't mean that I don't get angry
it doesn't mean that I don't get upset
but I'm going in the direction that I
want to be going in everyone has
unresolved areas where they are out of
alignment due to their upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted so some people might be
Health some people might be sex some
people it might be money some people it
might be their worth some people might
be all of the above whatever we've all
got it we've all got an area or many
where we are misaligned with the feeling
of love and abundance and and Grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay so the undoing of
the lack mentality is a journey of
clearing the belief systems from a
experiential time in your life right
that happens once again through books
like the universe has your back so
fantastic that you're doing that
transform fear to Faith excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural Pathways from the
experiences that we've had as children
particularly young childhood experiences
but the good news is thanks to
neuroplasticity our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our PTSD can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new Behavior so one thing that you can
do simply In This Moment is to notice
when you are in that lack mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method I've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes I could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy whichever one I hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but what you can do
for yourself you're here for self-help
you're here for Gabby to tell me how I
can serve myself you can be in the
proactive development of new thought
patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack Story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there is my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again all right I
forgive myself it just showed up again
because that forgiveness will dissolve
that guilt and tension and fear that
you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step choose the next best feeling
thought choose the thought of you know
what I just forgave myself for that
thought so I'm dissolving it in this
moment I actually am listening to the
universe has your back and it's so
supportive then I can actually go and
listen to Super tractor so you can go
from thought to thought to thought to
reach for the next best feeling thought
so your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you right and
especially if you're feeling afraid that
you're manifesting things because you're
having the thoughts then just forgive
the thoughts because or forgive yourself
for having the thought because the
moment that you say oh I forgive myself
for that thought or I forgive that
thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized I am not that
thought it's just a thought that I keep
thinking I am not that belief it's just
a thought that I keep thinking when I
was small mom I was also really
undersized so it's probably one of the
reasons I lift weights I was always
every baseball picture on the kid
holding a sign in the front right so I
was small and skinny they used to tease
me Eddie spaghetti you know and I'd get
bullied at school and I never retaliated
so I had that mixed with shyness mixed
with chaos in my home which many people
can relate to and I gotta tell you that
the shift for me Sports was good for me
because it gave me an out that I finally
found something that I was pretty good
at
I think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when I was a little boy I got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size I was fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business I said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're Relentless I am those things and
when someone linked those gifts to me
winning now I believed I could win
that's the other way to change identity
is when someone can link your giftedness
to the victory you'll believe it not
like you're great that's General that's
[ __ ] right but it's something you
know specific like for you right now you
wouldn't brag about there's a few things
you know you know what I am good at
these things right I've always been good
at these things it's natural for me and
when someone links back to you winning
like for you for example you're an
unbelievable interviewer you have this
General you you don't need to be the
smartest person in the room because you
probably are most of the time and so
there's a confidence no there's a
confidence that allows you to be present
when you interview me and just listen
that's different than anyone who's
interviewed me before and so that's a
natural giftedness for you which is why
there's a part of you that kind of knows
I am pretty you wouldn't say it but I am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way I changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and and using them in
my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was I suck I'm shy
I'm small I have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the weight is these are some gifts
God gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least I know I have and I can
spend my life using these gifts now I've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction
several years ago I went to see a friend
of mine and he is considered by all
means one of the leading experts in the
world on EEG and brainwave frequencies
and really understanding how our brain
waves affect
how we feel and what we think about and
I went to this biocybernaut institute to
be able to recognize one thing number
one was that my thoughts happened
randomly as a result of all of the years
of learning experiencing listening to my
parents my teachers my brother my sister
and myself and as a result of that I
developed these neural patterns or brain
patterns that created these automatic
thoughts some of them are positive some
of them were negative however what I
learned at The biocybernaut Institute
was that I could control my thoughts now
listen to me for just a moment if you
think about this are you your brain
well the answer is no your brain is an
organ however your brain has billions of
cells and those cells connect and talk
to each other every time you have a
positive thought you reinforce that
thought pattern every time you have a
negative thought you reinforce that
thought pattern even faster now the
reason that your brain does this is
because it wants to protect you from any
real or imagined danger and so a
negative thought is something that
happens in the brain that when it
happens it reinforces itself way faster
than the positive thought so one of the
things that you can do is this number
one is give your brain a command since
you're not your brain you can do this
and science has proven this you can give
your brain a command to let you become
aware of when you're having a negative
thought or even a negative emotion so
the first spot or the first part that
you need to take control over is the
awareness part of what's happening
within you
then the next part is to recognize and
realize that you don't have to play into
a negative thought you don't have to let
it control you you can actually observe
your negative thought you can observe
even a negative emotion or an unpleasant
emotion and you can surrender to it and
what does that mean surrender doesn't
mean give up surrender just means allow
it to happen without getting emotionally
attached to it now if you become aware
of an emotional or mental thought that
you have that's negative and you
surrender to it and just allow it to
Flow by you can use the word next in
order to give your brain a command to
move on to the next thought or to move
on to the next emotion and so as you're
aware of it as you surrender to it and
use the word next what I want you to do
next is refocus your brain on what you
want the thought to be and the emotion
to be so you can choose a polar opposite
thought
that will really Empower you to have the
right emotion and more importantly will
Empower you to take action around the
new thought and emotion so again the
three steps are become aware of your
thoughts and your emotions surrender to
them by allowing them to happen let them
go by release them by saying the word
next and then refocus your thoughts on
what you want to achieve what you want
to take action on and that way you'll
start to be in control of your thoughts
your emotions which will then drive the
behaviors that you want in order to
achieve the goals that are most
important to you just around two years
ago I had this idea I wanted to share
wisdom at a pace we wanted entertainment
I wanted to share wisdom in a way that
it could connect resonate and deeply
evolve the lives of people all over the
world for 10 years before that I'd been
working with individuals groups coaching
at universities companies and all of
these these opportunities but I really
wanted to serve and connect with
everyone across the world I wanted to
make wisdom accessible to anyone who had
one of these I have one of those so I
was excited I had the energy the
enthusiasm and I was pitching my idea to
every single company that was online now
remember this is before I ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
I was who's this guy I applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea I waited a day I waited two
days I waited a week I was rejected by
every single one of those companies
before interview none of them invited me
for a phone interview none of them
invited me for a video interview none of
them even connected with me in any
personal way that's rude I said to
myself it doesn't matter let's see what
else I can do to try and make my goal a
reality
so I tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance I got
one answer and one answer only they said
you're getting older now most of the
people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a masters and then
we'll take you seriously literally I was
getting rejected from every single
person I spoke to but inside of me I had
this desire I had this calling I had
this Mission I had this Vision that I
wanted to share everything that I had
learned with people out there I
genuinely tried every single possible
method I could to break into the media
industry to the point that the only
thing that was left that I could try was
to start a social media channel and of
course you know the rest the most
incredible thing is that it reminds me
of a really powerful thought from Thomas
Edison he once said when you believe
you've exhausted all options remember
this you haven't that thought stayed in
my mind the whole time what I learned
from all of this rejection from all of
this failure from all of these clear
no's was one really important thing and
today I want to give that as a gift to
you me if you have a dream you have an
idea you have a vision we have to take
the responsibility to prove our worth
before we expect anyone to value our
talent when I started crafting and
creating my own videos teaching myself
how to edit learning how to produce
understanding the mechanics of social
media when I started putting my energy
into that space that's when people
started to take notice that's when
people started to listen that's when
things started to happen
this is nice it's when I decided to take
the responsibility for sharing what I
was passionate about with the world and
not waiting for someone external to
validate me or give me permission or
allow me to do that that's what made the
difference if you're feeling you've been
going through a lot of rejections ask
yourself this is your deeper passion and
calling making you want to move further
number two have you truly knocked on
every single door and number three are
you working hard on investing in your
expertise and passion so that you really
have something impactful to offer I
think we've been hypnotized and
conditioned into becoming materialists I
think
that we Define reality with our senses
and I think that is one of the biggest
Illusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind that your
brain has literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred now the
latest research in plasticity says
that's absolutely possible and can you
select a new possibility in the quantum
field and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future every single day to such a
degree that your body as the unconscious
mind the objective mind does not know
the difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to Signal new genes in new ways to
change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future that your body begins to
change to look like it's already
happened now this is where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it now it begins to come
to you you become the vortex for the
magnet to your destiny so then people
who come out of their meditation and
they say well I just focused on my
wealth why isn't it there well you're
not that good if you're asking why isn't
it there you're back to the old person
again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as
an experiment as a scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then see what kind of effects begin
to take place without moving into
impatience without moving into
frustration without starting to analyze
why it hasn't happened or when that is
the Trap of defining reality with your
senses so you have the thought of your
future and you don't see it then you
experience separation but people who are
practicing this work they have the
thought of their future and they feel
the emotion of their future they're
still connected to it right so that
takes practice and it's just learning
like hitting a golf ball hitting a
tennis ball dancing the salsa you know
crocheting whatever it is you gotta you
gotta start out staying real conscious
and learning then you get good at it and
gets to be instrumental gets to be fun
and that's that's what I want for
everybody that the Act of Creation
should be a blissful life ecstatic loose
love free process and um and so
I love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future then
they're not living by the memories of
the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people the unknown is a
scary place so they don't see that
future because they're used to seeing
that future with evidence with their
senses and the you have to be able to
get beyond that and stay in the unknown
stay in that discomfort and then in that
moment to be begin to self-regulate like
oh I'm starting to feel a little anxiety
ooh I'm starting to feel a little
frustration that's the defining moment
where your body's going back to the past
because emotions are a record of the
past or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory and if you keep catching
yourself those victories add up and it's
not so much about your wealth or your
health or your freedom or your new
relationship
it's actually about who you become I
think we play small by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we haven't
trained in US
from a young age our parents our family
our friends our teachers think about who
did you learn about life from probably
people who didn't like their own life
you know who did you learn about careers
from probably people who did not have a
great career you know who barely are
enjoying what they're doing in their
work and they're living in scarcity
mindset of this is all I can do and
that's what we've learned from and you
know guidance counselors at school do
they love what they're doing I mean I
think this is a huge problem and we're
stuck living small and living scared and
living as a result way below our
potential of what we could do and who we
could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problems when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverage it's busting through
limiting beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wins without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
never accomplish their goals who don't
end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both
and so if you're not working hard then
you don't have a shot but assuming you
are working hard and you want a 10x
again then it's a shift in mindset and
the shift in living beliefs so how do
you identify the living beliefs how do
you figure out where it's holding your
back how do you break through the
Paradigm and hit a new level a lot of it
is environmental you know the the
current thinking that you have was
environmental it's your parents and your
family and your guidance counselor and
teachers and family Etc that's
environmental you've adopted their
beliefs and unfortunately a lot of them
are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably something a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever's more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people uh every day
but you know we can't so how do you do
it well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Muskan Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter and when somebody
asked me yesterday on Instagram do I
think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
said no I don't think you'll buy Twitter
but it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
in general right
you know lots of people have
underestimated him and he's proven them
wrong many many many times and I just
like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically be
thinking through it if you're if you
were running Tesla uh in SpaceX would
you have thought about buying Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at it hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if he
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles
in his early life and he if he can
overcome that to get to where he's at I
see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expensive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors what I call them an Elon Musk a
John Assaraf or Oprah Winfrey people who
who you
may never meet but you can still learn a
heck of a lot from
step two was to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you are in that things that used to
make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
conference an event you come back I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just just think about if
you're just constantly stuck it doesn't
mean you have to go travel on vacation
it may mean you take up salsa dancing it
may mean you try a new hobby take that
idea that you've got and just go go to
it look at any events that are happening
in your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class that you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at but he
wouldn't have known that unless he
dropped out of school and dropped in on
the calligraphy class so it's changing
the environments being a part of new
things it's it's not just staying stuck
in the same happen the same routines and
and same thing you're doing constantly
and that will inject newness that will
then allow you to be more creative and
create amazing opportunities for your
next goals so step one is to be around
aspirational mentors to be around the
people like an Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey
Etc watching videos content interviews
podcasts books that make you feel better
stronger more courageous step two is to
get out of your comfort zone and go go
to things physical things travel more
take take on classes say yes go to
conferences and events just so that you
expose yourself to new ideas and
opportunities and come up with fresher
ideas of what you could do with your
life and step three is to to actually
have humans in your life who you're
around who make you want to push and do
more and be better and this mean hey if
you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
Movie Makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know it's not Movie
Maker is something else but being around
other people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really struggled so find other
people who are on this journey that you
can do it with because when you feel
like you're doing it with other people
and you're not alone you'll be a lot
more productive a lot more effective and
have a lot more fun as well
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to raise
your standards and brainwash yourself
for Success check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition The Habit is when you've done
something so many times that the body
now knows how to do it better than the
mind so now the person running